hey wisecracks Jared again today we're
talking about a show that you've all
been requesting for a really long time
our favorite sci-fi nightmare black
mirror black mirror tackles a variety of
issues posed by technology and while it
may not have a consistent narrative
between episodes we've noticed one theme
that keeps coming back whether the show
is tackling virtual reality politics
social media or interspecies erotica
like mirror really loves spectacle if
watching Black Mirror gives you a
sinking feeling of bread or disgust it
may be because this idea of spectacle
isn't science fiction but is built into
the very fabric of our reality
welcome to news wisecrack edition on the
philosophy of black mirror and of course
spoilers ahead so what is spectacle it's
not just fireworks
Pro Wrestling or you're going to uncle
at Thanksgiving it's really any kind of
compelling visual display TV video games
the internet real life all these things
are essentially spectacles but if
there's one kind of spectacle that
pervades our daily reality it's a kind
that comes through our screen if you
have a notice black mirror is obsessed
with screen the show's promotional art
features a cracked screen and you know
the title is a reference to this the
relationship between screen and viewer
is central throughout the show in the
national anthem and on-screen spectacle
mesmerizes a nation while a performance
artist releases a hostage in broad
daylight in nosedive smartphone screens
and ice creams compel everyone to rate
their fellow humans just like one might
rate a hipster bar on Yelp in the Waldo
moment a screen literally becomes a
politician Paul Shedden and some of the
show's first moments visually emphasized
the screen surrounding the British
Cabinet we can better understand black
mirror screen fixation through the lens
of philosopher guida bored out in the
1960s the board suggested that
understanding spectacle was critical to
understanding society in the aptly named
society of the spectacle Gabor wrote
that in the decades following the
Industrial Revolution images and
appearances had begun to govern
world many of the protagonists in black
mirror experience spectacle in their own
way Bing is immersed by screens in 15
million merit white bear turns the
justice system into a literal spectacle
of justice but in the national anthem
the merits of pig sex are mostly
discussed in terms of public perception
strong on the kind of sympathy every
poll indicates public understanding
discussed with the come to outright to
the whole thing but not to you however
one of the most illustrative examples is
nosedive where a young woman named lacy
like many of us derives her self-worth
from her smartphone speaking of which
please don't forget to thumbs up this
video according to de Board the
spectacle is not a series of images but
a social relationship between people
that is mediated by images to
oversimplify we've been numbed by years
of advertising and mass culture and
because of that live shallow
disconnected lives a nosedive what we're
going to call Yelp for people as
re-engineered society into a new class
system based on popularity I just need
some stars please which is in turn based
on spectacular social media profiles and
fake kindness Laci constantly does
things she otherwise wouldn't she takes
photos of food she finds disgusting
and is overly nice to people who play an
accessory role in her life hope you're
having a great night it's pretty good
all in order to get positive ratings on
an app which attributes objective value
to people Nene is putting on a
ridiculous show whenever she opens a
device Wow Lacey's co-worker has to be
unnaturally kind and beg for positive
ratings they're from the organic stall
at the farmers market nobody is free to
be their authentic selves because as
Lacey says half of the world work people
develop relationships with their phones
and apps which in turn develop
relationships with other humans in other
words to recap the board our
relationships are mediated by images but
in this case images delivered by our
phones for the board the more we
recognize our own existence in the terms
set forth by the spectacle the less we
understand our own existence and our own
desires
what Lacey wants is simple a fancy new
house we'd need you around a four five
four point I for that change to boost
her social media score and make good
with Nene her high school friend who had
sex with Lacey's boyfriend intrude
aborting in fashion Lacey's increasing
immersion in the spectacle makes her a
hollow shell of her former self before
finally going cray-cray at Nene's
wedding
Lacey fails in both being herself and
being someone she's not the spectacle
has not only defined her desire but made
her a prisoner to it it's only when
Lacey is forcefully removed from
spectacle and thrown in jail that she
seems to find authenticity yeah but how
did we get here how did the Society of
spectacle take over the lives of Lacey
Bing Prime Minister callow and even our
own lives the board provides an answer
that resonates in Black Mirror the board
argues that spectacle is born when the
economy invades the very fabric of our
social lives in 15 million merits we see
what this economic invasion looks like
as entered
dictates every aspect of social life
being pointlessly rides a bike to
accumulate virtual currency he can only
spend on necessities entertainment or
his me he and everybody else lives in a
cube made with screens where he
constantly receives pop-up ads he has to
ignore things that exist outside of this
Makana me are frowned upon in one
telling scene paper origami is discarded
as garbage because it doesn't exist in
the circuit of labor and commodities
offered by what I'm going to call George
Orwell's favorite SoulCycle class I love
TV man clothes and I love gold feel like
it really expresses who I really am in
an attempt to escape the spectacle being
becomes obsessed with authenticity and
decides to do something meaningful for
someone else namely getting a woman he
heard singing in the bathroom a shot at
becoming famous something real
everything is that man what happened
here but some Simon Cowell wannabe has
other plans
till this pure beauty seems to be a
knockout ticket and this is sort of
interesting
innocence going on and that's something
I think rights erotica channels could
really play with the economic incentive
to pimp out ABI outweighs whatever hopes
and dreams she or being had being even
explicitly reflects on the way that the
economy has infiltrated their lives and
if they can afford a reason more you
love it because thankful is the only
thing that works anymore who we know is
thankful to bite that was sweet to each
other how we express ourselves as buying
but as we learn even dissent becomes a
commodity and I mean everyone in this
hall something we all agree on
authenticity is in rows very short
supply being gets a lavish apartment
everyone remains miserable and the
spectacle goes on literally this
economic invasion of everyday life or
debord
happens at a very specific moment when
being becomes having when who you are is
defined by what you have this logic is
everywhere in our own society wearing a
Dead Kennedys shirt makes you a rebel
guzzling Pepsi makes you an actor
and having a bumper sticker makes you
whatever kind of pretentious you aspire
to be black mirror follows this logic
but takes it a step further in be right
back a grieving woman purchases a
life-sized avatar of her boyfriend after
he dies he'll fight having a
relationship replaces being in a
relationship the shard of glass being
uses to threaten to kill himself
becomes a virtual commodity owning
rebellion replaces being rebellion
farewell forever to the same time you
see the Waldo moment further explores
what happens when this logic enters the
political sphere
it follows Gwendolyn Harris an aspiring
politician and Jamie Salter a comedian
who voices a foul-mouthed cartoon bear
that becomes a global icon the Waldo
moment focuses on the unreality of
politics
Gwendolyn truly wants to be a politician
but struggles with the spectacle of it
all while she seems genuinely concerned
with policy I wasn't attempting to
represent was also not a bollocks
everything her campaign is just a show
for her future aspirations how you
describe it it's like you're doing this
for a show real No so it's good exposure
you know go when you know you're not
gonna win while Jamie is a depressed
joke making nihilist hooba grudgingly
runs for office except people seem way
too into his message Waldo is pure
spectacle well there's no point in
attempting to converse with a cartoon Oh
converse Your Lordship thy flowery
language does give me a right throbbing
bow on
it's only metric for success seems to be
attention reduction morning everybody
while ignoring me mr. bono finally pull
it out we have our my roll on roll why
do we go in me and like any spectacle
it's pure image with no substance
Jamie constantly reminds us he's not
real but as it turns out that doesn't
seem to really matter well does not real
exactly that's what he said that really
hit home he's not real but he's realer
than all the others spectacle is bigger
than any of its individual actors an
autonomous system like if Skynet decided
to only care about cat videos and
reality TV and for the real politicians
like Monroe
we've always succeeded by a spectacle I
think we should have it as a round of
applause for children have they become
powerless in the face of a much better
spectacle a career politician someone
else less real to me and that can do
this Monroe's last-minute attempts to
appeal to real politics are pointless
because the spectacle had one long ago
Ford aboard the system gives us
competing spectacles that are nothing
more than vaporous quality meant to
stimulate loyalty to quantitative pure
reality in other words just as spectacle
compelled Yankees fans to hate Red Sox
fans it compels people to identify with
a blue bear who makes fart jokes the
system can profit as much from the
Yankees versus the Red Sox as I can from
Waldo versus the status quo everyone's
pissed with the status quo and Waldo
gives that voice well does a bear as
with being dissent is a commodity you
could roll this out worldwide like
Pringles absolutely or as the Board says
the smug acceptance of what exists can
also merge with purely spectacular
rebellion this reflects the simple fact
that dissatisfaction itself became a
commodity so here's a question are we
headed towards our inevitable
destruction like black mirror imagine
well maybe there's hope the show
balances its pessimism with the episode
San Junipero in which two dying women
fall in love in a simulated reality and
choose to live there for eternity
instead of accepting death in this world
perspective
of San Junipero isn't a nightmare but
literally heaven d'abord wrote the
society of the spectacle in the 60s so
he was mostly talking about a world
dominated by television radio movies and
mass advertisement he didn't see or
predict the advent of smartphones or
social media but he certainly foresaw
how they would shape society in a pretty
prophetic way so what do you think
wisecrack
well spectacle drive us to the hellish
world of black mirror or are we already
there hey guys thanks for watching to
watch some of my favorite episodes click
here or here to check them out and be
sure to subscribe and ring that bell to
get notified of our next videos there's
a lot to talk about in black mirror so
if you want to see us do some breakdowns
of individual episodes let us know in
the comments thanks for watching
wisecrack peace
[Music]